this is the reality not just numbers on
a chart real lives lost 10 meters long
and 2 meters wide this grave prepared
for multiple burials this is the first
time we've done this in this country so
it isn't typical but it's been done at
the request of needs of the Muslim
community who have come to us and said
we really need to be able to increase
the speed at which we can bury our loved
ones one prayer for 10 people Muslims
and Jews bury the dead as quickly as
possible
guidance that's remained unchanged for
centuries it speeds the souls ascent to
the heavens they say and opens the door
for those left behind to start grieving
cemeteries have become overwhelmed here
they've gone from 5 burials a week to 30
this is not a mass grave it is only to
accommodate and to ensure that in two
days they were able to dig up this grave
whereas imagine digging 10 individual
graves
it may take probably maybe over a week
and this a first for British Muslims ten
burials one straight after another this
method is described as soft alum watts
in Arabic that means rows of deceased
each individual is given their own
funeral rites before being buried in
rows it means multiple burials can take
place in a short period of time a most
extraordinary goodbye social distancing
means thirty-three year old are you
Arthur's family can't be here I went
outside and the most I could actually do
is just sit there wait five minutes not
be allowed anywhere and just come home
it's just difficult last time I saw my
brother it's been three weeks and he
left in the ambulance and that was the
last time I saw you
nothing demonstrates the human cost of
the coronavirus like watching ten
burials take place in the time it would
normally take to do just one but these
aren't normal times and there aren't
just ten bodies the site for the next
South burial has already been prepared
Sadia Chaudhary skinny's